What's up everybody? Welcome to Candid
Truth. We're going to talk about the
truth and we're going to get candid with
it. Five things you didn't know about
Halloween. It's hard to believe that we
even have to talk about this subject,
but you would not believe how many
Christians these days are still
celebrating this satanic originated
holiday. Do you know where this all
started? There was a pagan holiday
called sawin Halloween. Notice it says
alternative titles all hallow's eve and
related topics all saints day holiday
sawin. So they the encyclopedia
bratannica associates sawin with
Halloween. There's a very good reason
for that because that's what Satan does.
He just wears many different disguises.
So in the past there was a lot of idol
worship. You had Baal and uh Diana and
all these things. And these days, we're
like, we don't worship idols. Oh, but we
got Cardi B and we got Lil Wayne and we
got all these idols, right? But even so,
comic authors will tell you that these
new superheroes are literally just pagan
gods repackaged, that Batman is Hades,
that Superman is Zeus. So, Satan just
loves to redisguise his tricks. And so,
the same thing has happened with
holidays. If you haven't seen the pagan
origins of the holidays, check out that
video. Aubrey went through tons of them.
It's only part one of of three parts and
it's a threehour presentation. That's
how deep this stuff gets. Aubry is going
to be covering Halloween even deeper on
another video coming out soon. But let's
let's keep looking at this. So, still in
Britannica,
Halloween had its origins in the
festival of Sawin. So, they're saying it
right out. It says among the Kelts of
the ancient Britain and Ireland on the
day corresponding to November 1st on
contemporary calendars, the new calendar
was believed to begin. The date was
considered the beginning of the winter
period. So this this is all about
solstesses and celebrating certain
seasons and everything. It says u the
date on which herds were returned from
pastures and from pasture and land
tenures were renewed. Now here's a
highlighted part. During the sin
festival the souls of those who had died
were believed to return to visit their
homes and those who had died during the
year were believed to journey to the
other world. So this is a celebration of
the dead visiting back their homes. But
what does the Bible say about the dead?
It says the dead know nothing. The deads
return not to their homes. So what is
the Bible trying to keep us from being
involved in necromancy? Why? Because
necromancy is not talking to the dead,
but literally talking to Satan and
demons disguising themselves as your
dead loved ones. Now this holiday sawin
started with the dead returning to their
homes. It's a deception, a satanic
deception. Time magazine, this is Time
website says, "What is sawin? What to
know about the ancient pagan festival
that came before Halloween?" And it
says, "Dressing up in costumes and
trick-or-treating are popular Halloween
activities, but few probably associate
these lighthearted fall traditions with
their origins in Sawin, the 3-day
ancient Celtic pagan festival.
So they're solidifying the fact that
this is from Sawin. This is where this
originated from. According to historian
Nicholas Rogers, author of Halloween,
from pagan ritual to party night, sawin
was a time of stocktaking and perhaps
sacrifice.
Yes, you heard that right. Sawin had
sacrifices involved, human and animal.
We're going to go through and find out
more about that. It says, including
probably animal sacrifice during which
pastoral communities prepared to survive
the winter. I just think that's
pastoral. I don't know what kind of
pastor, but pastoral communities.
It continues and says, "The spiritual
undertones of the sin festival also lent
themselves to looking to the future." So
now we're talking about divination,
using crystal balls and Ouija boards,
trying to know the future from the
spirit realm. Not not like the future
according to Bible prophecy, but going
to the spirit world to find out what the
future holds. This is fortunetelling
divination. An activity quite a a what I
proposed to the start of the Celtic new
year. History.com notes that druids or
Celtic priest again we got this
religious aspect. Celtic priest priests
thought that the presence of other
worldly spirits made it easier to make
predictions about the future. So they're
saying, "Hey, this time of year between
Octo, you know, somewhere around October
31st, the veil is thin between us and
the other world, the spirits of the
dead. And uh we should be able to find
out the future easier." That's what
Ouija boards are all about, right? We
want to know the future. We want to
communicate with beings on the other
side, right? And October 31st would be
the perfect time to do that if you were
trying to communicate with a demon. And
that's what's going on.
History Channel. Uh you see this picture
of this pagan
uh practicer right here and it goes on.
It says, "Sawin is a pagan religious
festival originating from an ancient
Celtic spiritual tradition. In modern
times, sawin, a Gaelic word pronounced
sawin, is usually celebrated from
October 31st to November 1st to welcome
in the harvest and usher in the dark
half of the year. Celebrants believed
that the barriers between the physical
world and the spirit world were would
world break down during sawin allowing
more interaction between humans and
denisin of denisens of the other world.
So are we supposed to be communicating
with beings from the other world from
the other side from uh the dead? No.
This is necromancus. Strongly forbidden
by God because God doesn't want us to
communicate with demons. Case closed.
God knows that Satan is out here trying
to deceive the entire world. And what
happens as Christians? Many Christians
are dressing up their kids and saying,
"Yay, let's celebrate. I love
Halloween." You know how many people I
see that are just like as soon as it
gets to be like September, they're like,
"Ooh, Halloween." and they start posting
all these memes and it shows Michael
Myers like dancing and stuff and they're
so excited about Halloween.
Actually, I seen an article. I wish I
would have put it in here, but it
happens every year. Almost every year it
makes the news that somebody has to take
down their uh Halloween decorations
because they're they're too grotesque.
Uh, the one I just saw recently was a
woman, some middle-aged woman had body
bags hanging from their necks in her
tree, and somebody was like, "This is
triggering. This is like, this is
terrible." And yes, it is. Why would you
want some realistic looking people
hanging from trees in your yard? Do you
not realize that death is not a joke?
Death is not funny. Many people have had
to go to their children's, their
parents, their family members funerals,
and you're going to hang body bags from
a tree in your yard yard and think it's
just fun. No, this is ridiculous. Why do
we, why are we so sadistic in these days
that we think this is acceptable? And
that's why people love Halloween.
Um it says the wheel I c I was
considered what the wheel I the wheel
was considered a representation of the
sun and used along with prayers. Again
we got the religious aspect here. Cattle
were sacrificed. So there are sacri this
is a religious ritual that involves
sacrifices to a god. You don't make
sacrifices unless you're offering them
to a god. This is a pagan sun worship
festival. Sawin as a mandatory
celebration.
So this is going back to when it was
mandatory. It says and participants took
a flame from the communal bonfire back
to their home and relight the hearth.
Early text present sawin as a mandatory
celebration lasting three days and three
nights where the community was required
to show themselves to local kings and
chieftains. Failure to participate was
believed to result in punishment from
the gods, usually illness or death.
Yeah, I'm guessing that these people
didn't really get killed by gods, but
probably someone else, right? You didn't
celebrate. Off with your head. Number
two, you didn't know about this.
Costumes. Why are we wearing costumes?
Why? What? Every uh holiday just has
these weird traditions and we don't know
where they started from. Why mistletoe
at Christmas time? Why even bring a tree
into your house and decorate it? Where
where do these things come from? Easter
bunnies and eggs and you know where do
these traditions come from? We we don't
know. We just do it. Hey, it's fun.
Costumes. Why are we dressing up our
kids in costumes and sending them out?
Uh, Britannica again, it says, "People
set bonfires on hilltops for relighting
their hearth fires for the winter and to
frighten away evil spirits, and they
sometimes wore masks and other disguises
to avoid being recognized by the ghost
thought to be present. It was in those
ways that beings such as witches,
hobgoblins, fairies, and demons came to
be associated with with the day. The
period was also thought to be a favor to
be favorable for divination,
trying to get the future, trying to find
out information from quote unquote
ghosts and dead people. This is
communication with demonic beings,
fallen angels, spirits. Um, and it says
on matters such as marriage, health, and
death, when the Romans conquered the
Kelts in the first century CE, they
added their own festivals of Furelia
commemorating the passing of the dead
and of Pomona, the goddess of the
harvest. So here we see the goddess
Pomona. And this is why there was
sacrifices offered
time. We're going to look at, you know,
we're going to just keep showing
different secular sources to solidify
this. Um, and it says many participants
also dawned costumes, often masquerading
as animals or beasts in hopes of footing
spirit fooling in hopes of fooling
spirits who might want to harm them. For
one, I think it's pretty ridiculous that
you think you're going to fool a spirit.
But this is why they wore costumes
because the veil is thin and they think
that the the living and the dead are
mingling together and the spirit world
is entering into our world during this
time and out of fear we wear costumes in
hopes that the demons don't recognize
that we're human and we're a demon and
they will leave us alone. This is
ridiculous. This is satanic. History
Channel says it was expected that
ancestors might cross over during this
time. ancestors, dead ancestors might
cross over into our world during this
time as well. And Kelts would dress as
animals and monsters so that fairies
were not tempted to kidnap them. This is
what we're doing when we dress up in
costumes. We are practicing a pagan
religious ritual all about demons and
trying to fool demons and spirits and
fairies.
Number three. This is number three of
the things you didn't know about
Halloween. Bonfires. Why do we have
bonfires? I love a fire. I love sitting
next to a fire, but I don't call it a
bonfire for a reason.
Uh Miriam Webster says, "The secret
history behind secret history of
bonfires. A good fire made of bones."
Bone fire. Bones of what? Bones of who,
might we ask?
I'm not putting bones in my fire.
Says bonfires are typically associated
with celebrations, backyard burnings,
and toasting marshmallows. And although
these are all good things, the bonfire
and bon the bon and bonfire isn't
related to the French for good. So, it's
not bon voyage or whatever. Uh it
doesn't mean good in French. Instead,
bonfire actually stems from the Middle
English bone fire. Literally referring
to a fire of bones.
This is sacrifice. This is where this
came from. Human sacrifice during this
time of season. You're going to find out
by the end of this where all this came
from. Bonefire.
Uh true origin of bone fire is the word
is actually derived from middle English.
bonefire meaning literally a fire of
bones.
Bonfires were also held in worship of
saints. Okay, for one, we are not
supposed to be worshiping saints. I
don't know if anybody out there doesn't
know that, but uh when disciples fell at
angels feet, they said, "Get up. I'm not
worthy." There's only one that we should
be worshiping. Christ alone. God and
Christ. And u no one else. No, it
doesn't matter who the saint is. is it
doesn't matter if it's Peter or Paul
himself or Moses. I'm not worshiping
Moses. You're not supposed to worship
saints or anyone else.
Time continues and it says during this
festival the world of the gods was
believed to be made visible to humankind
leading the supern leading to
supernatural tricks and trouble. Ghost
of the dead and spirits which is a
deception. There's no such thing as
ghost of the dead
from the other world were also thought
to return to the earth during sawin to
appease deities during this time.
Sacrifices generally of crops and
animals were burned in bonfires. This is
why there's bones in the fire because
there's a sacrifice to deities on this
time of year. And it says were burned in
bonfires as a protective measure from
the evil. Otherworldly beings as
offerings were left out for other
visiting mischievous spirits. Tricks and
pranks were often played but blamed on
fairies and spirits during the 3-day
period when the line between the two
worlds were blurred. So, this is when
people start doing tricks. Trick or
treat, right? They start doing tricks
and they're like, "Oh, it wasn't me. I
didn't egg your house. a fairy did or a
spirit did. But this is where this all
started. It says that bonfires were to
appease the demons to keep them from,
you know, harming them. Look, we made
you a sacrifice. We're burning something
or somebody right now. Number four,
jacko'lanterns.
Jacko'Lantern. What in the world is up
with the jacko'lantern? There's
something with that. National
Geographic. It says, "The twisted
transatlantic tale of American
jacko'lanterns says, "Celtic rituals,
tricks of nature, and deals with the
devil have played a part in creating
this iconic symbol of Halloween." Wow.
Really, enough said, right? Why do we
even need to go any further? A
jacko'lantern originated from a deal
with the devil. Early Celtic rituals.
The concept of using a round fruit or
vegetable to depict a human face goes
back thousands of years. In some
northern European Celtic centuries, it
may have it may even have had
pre-Christian origins that evolved from
the custom of head veneration. Wait,
head veneration? This is decapitated
heads, like shrunken heads on your shelf
or something. Head veneration. or
potentially even represented war
trophies. Exactly. Keeping the head of
somebody taken from your foes.
This is in this is sadistic. When you
make a jacko'lantern, it's paying homage
to the decapitated head of someone's
enemies in the past.
Uh says Nathan Manian, senior cur
curator for Epic, the Irish Immigration
Museum in Dublin. It's quite macabre,
but it may have symbolized the severed
heads of your enemy. That's what you're
doing when you carve a pumpkin with your
child. You're memorializing the severed
head of someone's enemies. Is that what
we should be doing? Like, it's so sick
the things that we do these days. And I
know like this is something that we grew
up with as tradition. And so, we didn't
know these things. We did it out of
ignorance, right? But when the light of
truth comes to us, we, you know, even
the Bible says that God winks at our
sins committed in ignorance. If we do
something unknowingly, God winks at it.
We can't be held accountable for a sin
that we're doing that we don't even know
about. Right? But then that verse
continues on and it says, but and I'm
paraphrasing, when the light of truth
comes, then it's up to us to make the
choice. We have to follow that truth.
So, if this is your first time hearing
this, the truth will set you free. I'm
letting you know the truth. When you
carve a pumpkin into a jacko'lantern,
it's a satanic, sadistic tradition about
decapitated heads, about decapitating
your enemy and keeping it as a trophy.
The idea took deeper hold during the
Celtic festivals of Sawin, which was
originally celebrated on November 1st
and inspired many traditions of
modern-day Halloween. On Sawin Eve,
October 31st, spirits of the dead were
thought to mingle with the living. To
ward the to ward off restless souls,
people dawned costumes. We read this
already, but this is where where we
talked about this. People dawned
costumes and carved frightening faces
into root vegetables such as beets,
potatoes, and turnups, usually plentiful
after the recent harvest. So, not only
did they wear costumes to frighten off
demons, but they were carving heads and
putting them on their porch to scare off
the demons as well. So, do we really
believe that a a carving and a vegetable
is going to ward off demons? No. This is
some black magic ritual junk. This is
like burning sage thinking that you're
scaring off demons. This is satanic. I
hope no Christian out there is burning
sage in their home to ward off evil
spirits. That is a satanic practice. Do
not get involved in that stuff.
Encyclopedia.com
says the Celtic head cult. Um it says,
"But the cult of the head went far
beyond the pursuit of marital glory."
Marital glory. Let me full screen this
for you guys because it's small.
But the cult of the head went far beyond
the pursuit of merit of marshall glory.
Okay. Of marshall glory. The head was
not only a prized heroic trophy but also
a profoundly religious symbol. Whoa.
Profoundly religious symbol. sometimes
evidently representative of a deity and
generally suggestive of supernatural
wisdom and power. It was a source of
prosperity, fertility, and healing as
well as
an apatrophic
I don't know
agent to ward off evil from the
individual and from the community as a
whole. Severed heads are often
associated with with sacred wells
themselves instruments of healing in the
archaeological record in the early in
insular literature in a modern oral
tradition and the association with and
the association was carried over into
the legends of the Christian saints.
Okay, this is insane, dude. This is
about a head cult.
A head cult that was about warding off
demons. And this is insane. And also
about healing. They kept this head as a
religious ritual because they believed
that healing would come from it. That it
would ward off demons. Dude, this is
sadistic on every level.
People have been making jacko'lanterns
at Halloween for centuries. The practice
originated from an Irish myth about a
man named Stingy Jack. According to the
story, Stingy Jack invited the devil to
have a drink with him. Oh yeah. Should
we be doing that? True to his name,
Stingy Jack didn't want to pay for his
drink, so he convinced the devil to turn
himself into a coin that Jack could use
to buy their drinks. Once the devil did
so, Jack decided to keep the money and
put it in his pocket. next to a silver
cross which prevented the devil from
changing back into his original form.
That's crazy, right? This is about a
deal with the devil. That's where the
jacko'lantern. Stingy Jack came from.
Number five, games. The games at
Halloween. What kind of games were
played at Halloween? Let's take a look
at some. Dumb supper. This is from
History Channel. Not a Christian,
religious, nothing. Dumb supper says the
tradition of dumb supper began during
this time in which food was consumed by
celebrants but only after inviting
ancestors to join in. This is talking
about dead ancestors. You're inviting.
Now remember this, Satan only has
authority to come into your life when we
allow him to. This is how the rules
work. And we do that in many different
ways that we don't understand. Sometimes
it's we're playing worldly secular
music. Sometimes we're watching horror
movies. That stuff invites demons in.
Sometimes you're drinking spirits.
Literally drinking alcohol is called
spirits. Sometimes you're smoking
marijuana, intoxicating your mind. That
that peace pipe. This is a religious
ritual. We do a lot of things that we
think are traditional and cultural and
acceptable and it's inviting demons into
your home. Let alone talking about this
dumb supper where you invite your
ancestors
to join you in a meal. It says, "Giving
the families a chance to interact with
the spirits until they left following
dinner. Children would play games to
entertain the dead while adults would
update the dead on the past year's news.
That night, doors and windows might be
left open for the dead to come in and
eat cakes and or that had been left for
them." This kind of reminds me of Santa
Claus, too, right? comes in the chimney,
eats the cookie and the milk that was
left out for him. Right? The these
traditions just go all the way across
all these crazy holidays.
Neither new holiday uh did away with the
pagan aspect of the celebration. October
31st became known as All Hallow's Eve.
Hallow. What does that mean? Hallowed
means holy. We already call these things
holidays. That means a holy day. But all
Hallow's Eve is just right in your face
that this is a a sacred or religious day
and yet we're participating in it. It's
all about ghouls and ghosts and demons
and skeletons. It says all Hallow's Eve
or Halloween and contained much of the
traditional pagan practices before being
adopted in 19th century America through
Irish immigrants bringing their
tradition across the ocean.
Trick-or-treating. That's one of the
games that's played, right? Is said to
have been derived from ancient Irish and
Scottish practices in the nights leading
up to sawin. In Ireland, mummying was
the practice of putting on costumes. So,
trick-or-treating uh came from ancient
Irish practices and it was about putting
on costumes and going doortodoor. Right
here, highlighted going door todo and
singing songs to the dead. cakes were
giving us payment. So today, trick or
treat, smell my feet, give me something
good to eat, singing songs, right? And
then what happens? The person at the
door gives you little Debbie cakes or
candy or whatever, right? Still the same
thing happens. Trick-or-treating, going
door to door, singing songs, and getting
treats. Vice. This is a a very
wellproduced production company that
puts out documentaries and they do a lot
of great research. And they said, "The
forbidden fruit at the root of
humanity's falling out with God is often
illustrated as an apple. Cut an apple in
half and you will find a fiveointed star
or pentagram often associated with
Satanism and the occult. More recently,
apples have been used in metal videos to
convey images of creepy paganism. So,
you will see apples in a lot of these
horror movies and things like that. It's
always associated with the Garden of
Eden, even though the Bible never
specifies that it was an apple or what
kind of fruit it was, but in art from a
long time ago and today, that's how it
was associated. Today, most
trick-or-treaters who get apples are
unaware of the dark past. So, I guess
that even when I used to go
trick-or-treating as a kid, I never got
an apple from anybody, but I've
definitely heard of the razor blade and
the apple type thing. And it says, uh,
trick-or-treaters who get apples are
unaware of the dark past and discard
them immediately, presumably because of
their lower sugar content than the rest
of their loot. Instead, we mostly enjoy
them dunked in caramel or bobbed from
huge vats of water by children with tied
up hands in the popular Halloween ritual
known as apple bobbing. Do you know
where this came from? Apple bobbing. I
mean, it already sounds bad. The child's
hands are tied up behind their back as
they're bobbing for apples. I don't
know. Maybe it just sounds innocent, but
we'll we'll see.
Proponents of this theory claim that
sawin, which also takes place on October
31st, was prime time for offering
humans,
offering humans to the gods. This is a
human sacrifice. Supposedly, the Druids
of the British Isles would force
villagers to bob apples from huge
cauldrons of scalding hot liquid and get
their faces scaldled or be decapitated
and thrown into a burning wicker man if
they refused. An offer that sounds way
more hardcore than trick-or-treating.
You ever heard of Burning Man? These big
festivals where they have this big
wicker man and they set it on fire. that
is also pagan in origin and it's all
about human sacrifices. People would be
put inside that wicker man and set on
fire. But the bobbing for apples is all
about you have a choice. We will burn
you alive or take your chance and bob
your head. If you get an apple in this
boiling hot water, then we'll let you
go, but your face is going to be burned
off, melted off. It says that makes for
a great Halloween story, but it doesn't
mean it's true. We spoke to Tony
Lockach, a writer and current-day druid,
to unpack the murky past of apple
bobbing and to better understand the
occult significance of the apple. So,
they're saying, "Look, this is just kind
of hearsay uh lure or myth or whatever,
but I believe it's true. I mean, all
this other stuff about sacrifice and to
the gods and all these things were
true." Time magazine said, "However,
whether Halloween celebrants know it or
not, they're following the legacy of the
ancient Kelts who with the festival of
Sawin celebrated the inevibility of
death and rebirth." So they're telling
you, look, when you practice this thing,
when you participate in Halloween,
whether you like it or not, you are
participating in pagan rituals. We're
going to look at some verses that say
not to do this. There was a book, a very
proclaimed book called The Worship of
the Dead. And in it, there was a lot of
great research from historical facts.
And this says, "Trickorreat came from
the fact that the Druid priests would go
doortodoor demanding a human sacrifice
for their religious rituals. If one was
not provided, the house was marked with
a hexag." That's a six-pointed star, the
one that we call the Star of David. It's
not a Star of David. It's a hexog. It's
a very occultic symbol. The priest would
later burn down the house or work some
evil against the family. The human
sacrifices were tied and dragged behind
a wagon until all victims in the
community were collected. A bone fire
would be built and the victim was asked
if they want to be put to death
immediately or if they would like to try
their luck at bobbing for apples in
boiling oil.
The Kelts and Druids celebrated this
3-day fire festival from October 29th to
October 31st, ending with their high
holy day. These bonfires or bone fires
were called beltins or bells fire. What
does that sound like? Baal or Baal was a
was the Celtic god of light or sun god.
This is why I said this is about sun
worship because this is all going back
to Baal worship. If you haven't watched
our video on who is the rain man, check
out that video right after this. The
link will be uh at the card at the end.
But Baal worship is still alive and well
in our culture today. When you talk
about the rainman, I'm not going to give
it away. Check out that video. It says
the light or the sun god. It has been
usual to identify the worship of the
Celtic of the Celtic Baal with that of
Baal or Bell of the Phoenicians
and other Semitic nations. On this day,
they worshiped spirits of the dead. We
already saw that was true.
Now, let's go to the scriptures. Why is
all this important? Why do we care?
Like, can't we just have fun? Are you
just trying to take away all our fun?
Look, I love fun. I think there's tons
of ways to have fun without celebrating
some pagan ritual. Look, if you want to
go ride a bike, go ride a bike. You want
to climb a tree, climb a tree. You want
to play games, ring toss or whatever, do
those things. But we should be staying
far away from anything that has these
roots in pagan origins. Why? Listen to
Deuteronomy 12:30 through32. It says,
"Take heed to thyself that thou be not
snared by following them." We shouldn't
be ins snared by following what they did
in the past and what they still do
today. After that, they be destroyed
from before thee. These people are going
to be destroyed. Why would we follow
what they're doing? And that thou
inquire not after their gods, saying,
"How did these nations serve their
gods?" Yeah. How did they serve Baal?
How did they serve all these other pagan
gods? The son god.
Even so, I will do likewise. He's
saying, don't do this. Don't say, how
did these nations serve their gods? And
even so will I do likewise. Thou shalt
not do unto the Lord thy God. For every
abomination to the Lord which he hateth
have they done unto their gods. God
says, I hate the things they're doing to
their gods. I hate when they carve a a
pumpkin or something in the in
veneration of somebody's severed head. I
hate when they bob for apples and make
it a game of what they used to do to
these people. He says, "I hate it. For
even their sons and their daughters,
they have burnt in the fire to their
gods." It literally says it in the
verse.
What things soever I command you,
observe to do it. Thou shalt not add
there to or diminish from it. God says,
"Look, I've told you what to do. Don't
add to it and don't take away from what
I've asked you to do." So, this verse
goes for all these holidays. We can't
say, "Oh, I know I know Easter was
really about Ishtar and it's really a a
pagan holiday, but I keep it in honor of
Jesus resurrection." This verse
literally says, "Don't do that." It
says, "Don't look at how they honored
their gods and do it unto me." I hate
it. Same thing with Christmas. Don't
say, "Well, I know Christmas was a pagan
holiday, but we celebrate the birth of
Christ." Don't do it. Stay away from
that. Stay away from all those
traditions. God says he hates them.
This verse says, "Be not equally un be
not unequally yolked together with the
unbelievers. For what fellowship hath
righteousness with unrighteousness?
And what communion hath light with
darkness? And what concord hath Christ
with bile? Or what part hath he that
believeth in an infidel? Look, he says
that light and dark can't mix. They
can't coexist together. If we are
children of the light, why would we be
participating in Halloween? Why would we
be dressing up like skeletons? And even
if we dress up like a a saint or, you
know, an apostle or Jesus or something,
why would we be doing anything any of
these pagan rituals that go back to Baal
worship? God says, "Don't do it. We need
to stay far away from these things."
What
what fellowship does righteousness have
with unrighteousness? None.
1 Thessalonians 5:21-23
says, "Prove all things. Hold fast to
that which is good. Let's just stick
with what's good. Abstain from all
appearance of evil." Let me ask you an
honest question. Let me ask you a
question. You be honest with yourself.
Does Halloween look evil? Yes or no?
Just it's a simple answer. Don't Don't
beat around the bush. Does Halloween
look evil? When you go to the stores and
you see grim reapers and Freddy Krueger
and demons everywhere, does it look
evil? Be honest with yourself. Abstain
from all appearance of evil. And the
very God of peace sanctify you holy. And
I pray God your whole spirit and soul
and body be preserved blameless unto the
coming of our Lord Jesus Christ. This
verse is saying,
"Be blameless until Christ returns. I
believe he's coming soon, and I want to
be ready when he comes. I don't want to
be messing around with pagan holidays,
with all these things that date back to
Baal worship. I don't want to be mixing
light and darkness. What does
righteousness have messing around with
unrighteousness? What does light have to
do with mixing around with darkness?
Let's abstain from all appearance of
evil. Here's just a a couple samples of
what Halloween's all about. Severed
heads,
ghosts, witches. You know, the Bible
strongly forbids witchcraft. It was a
death sentence if a witch was found.
I pray that something said here was
eyeopening for you. that you will begin
to at least consider not keeping this
holiday and potentially all the other
holidays as well that have been that
have become just a cultural thing in our
society today. Look at those things.
Investigate. It's cool to use your
brain. It's cool to be smart. That's
what this channel is all about. We want
to know the truth because the truth will
set you free. Please consider what I've
shown you in this video. Do the research
yourself. Don't just participate in
these crazy traditions that we don't
know where they started from. If you
like this video, give it a thumbs up,
please. It helps this video get out into
the algorithm so that more people can
see this video. If you're not a
subscriber, click that subscribe button.
Click the bell notification so you won't
miss another video. We love you guys.
God bless you. We'll see you next time.